do it yeah i was telling them how you
you were getting ready for your birthday
at one point you were doing
sun and lockdown um and they know that
sun
yes hey the hype train is an incoming
kids
yes trey mock gifted a bunch of tier one
subs man
got that hype train running uh
dr izzo subscribed with prime they've
subscribed for four months
yes thank you sir thank you um really
quick while we're here
so i was trying to tell everyone to go
to do watch sun and lockdown episode
eight
do you know why eight is not on there
but every other one
that what they do is they take it down
when they put the new one up they take
the previous one down
so you can't find uh austin though who's
in the show who's the son in lockdown
he uh is uh he puts him up on his
channel so you could always if you just
search sun and lock down you can watch
him there
but more importantly go click on oh look
at the hype train is about to turn into
mj2 just gifted 10 tier 1 subs ladies
and gentlemen
this is the greatest thing that's ever
happened to humanity since the son of
god
came to save our souls well done man and
that takes us
is that a level 2 hype train yeah we're
through we're just clear we're about to
get through level two because we're at
98
so level one already happened yes sir
mj2 just took us
almost to the top of level two man
and i have this this month what i'm
doing is the top sub gifter
is getting some fun stuff lee always
me says kevin are you still pissed that
maul rats
flopped at the box office even though
everyone loves it uh i don't know that i
was ever
pissed more disillusioned and more like
oh i must suck at my job
but i do know that like you know the
world [ __ ] embracing mall rats like
10 years after moretz came out and ever
since
certainly has more than made up for like
a lack of
box office i mean i learned that lesson
pretty honor early on in my career
that their story's never over
like you know just when we thought mall
rats
died at the box office and that was that
and we were ruined
mall rats is the movie that most people
talk to me about today
stands in it like it kind of accurately
predicted what the world would look like
today comic book culture pop culture is
the dominant culture
so the movie aged incredibly well that's
not because i'm smart i just got [ __ ]
lucky that the world shifted
in that direction so you're absolutely
right any sort of like
negativity i felt about mall rats not
being seen when it came out
has been more than made up for by the
reputation it's earned
since people seem to really dig it and
stuff so that
that felt good man but yeah it smarted
when the movie didn't like do well you
know it's tough when you
like get a bunch of people working on
something that costs like money real
like a couple million bucks and then you
know the whole world's like [ __ ] you
you know [ __ ] yoga hosers you know like
i thought it was clever
you know sometimes you're not as clever
as you think that's what i've learned
over the course of a career
but i've also learned that some
of the story's never done so mall rats
came out and flopped i was like we're
ruined
mall rats is the movie then now bowie's
my career uh
jersey girl came out and flopped and or
people [ __ ] on it really and
you know i was like oh my god it'll
never and then now jersey girl is a
movie that a lot of people like
movies not bad why do people always give
it [ __ ] like people forget that it
like all the [ __ ] i remember and you
know they just see a movie
years later and they're like george
carlin's in it and he's amazing
so that movie has also kind of slowly
been redeemed or whatever the [ __ ] you
would call it um and the weirdest one
you know that i'm still waiting for is
yoga hosers they'll take a minute
it'll take a minute but sooner or later
there'll be a day when i'm the only one
that remembers that yoga hoser was was a
flop
hopefully if it's anything like mall
rats and anything like jersey girl
it will slowly drift out into the
audience and find
welcome homes where people like this is
my jam this movie
defines me that's how i found strange
brew bob and doug mckenzie i was i was
watching the movie channel
which was like one of the first cable
channels we had in our neck of the woods
kind of like an hbo or showtime
they put up this trailer for uh uh
strange brew the adventures of bob and
doug mckenzie it was just basically the
first like few minutes of the movie and
i was like what the [ __ ] is
this then i watched and i was like this
is my religion
this is what this is this is who i meant
to be in life without bob and doug
mckenzie
you don't get to jay in some bob so that
was a movie too that like you know
didn't take the world by
by storm like the world on fire found
its audience over time a lot of my stuff
has done that and so it's done that
enough over the my entire career
that when yoga hoses died i was like all
right you know
start the clock uh like sooner or later
someone's gonna find it based on my
experience and stuff and i'm not going
to say
it'll be as celebrated as mall rats no
although stan lee
is in both
yeah maybe i don't get a stan lee pass
in the future people be like yoga hosers
that's one of stan lee's last
performances
um god bless me it's mod blessed stan we
miss him anyway
sorry guys we've never not got a level
five hype train with kevin here
are we gonna disappoint the boy no i'm
just kidding yeah
you're letting you're letting me down
somehow
i'm mad at you because i need the hype
it's true though we got a minute left
and we're not even gonna get to level
four on the hype train i'm a little
worried
all that chit chat has [ __ ] doomed us
you got me talking about my failures and
people like i ain't giving him no
chips what do they call bits i'm giving
him no hype
he's not getting the hype one minute
left and we're only at 41
all right now we're talking 64 thanks to
the cardboard cowboy we guilted them
into five
tier one subs man yes
thank you car boy i watched dude i want
to show you
cardboard he's awesome you show me bro
i watched you last night i'm sorry i
didn't say anything because i was in my
house and
my wife and my kid were asleep bro 38
37. explain it 30 seconds 30 seconds 35.
34. come on we're going to miss it
the hype train is coming to a halt for
some reason oh my god i got to pull out
my wallet and
give some tier one subs i don't even
know what it means
we need the hype train if the hype train
stops at level three
i'm out of here just walking oh don't do
it i'm walking i
only signed up for five levels seconds
ten seconds you got twenty five percent
can we do it
oh my lord you're gonna take us there
it's two for one percent
ten come on heights they need the hard
trade
ah you did it kids this happiest day of
my life
just like vegas i've won nothing all
right we've made it to level four
there was one percent with like three
seconds that was like indiana jones
grabbing his hat from under the [ __ ]
well done everybody never thought i'd
spend my life
begging for bits on twitch but it's a
good life
emerald night thank you we're level four
now so let me explain this
yeah go so the gift suburbs this month
i'm doing something different i'm giving
them
these pictures behind me see behind me
the j and bob uh
you can look that way the jay and bob me
and you yeah and that painting yeah
for the for the top gift suburb i'm
giving that painting
a signed by me and you i i'm an actress
that's a real painting
well well yeah the other one is and then
that one both of them well
the top ones the painting that's based
on that map yeah yeah
yeah i want that painting oh okay ladies
and gentlemen i just won
i won the hype train well the other line
he's not that's that's a one of a kind i
know i'll frame that [ __ ] put
xbox there's an xbox uh there's there's
well can you do something to replace it
what do you think at your home that's
sentimental but not too sentimental
oh like a shirt or something use my
malphone you can't curse right because
kids yeah yeah
you try not to but you can i mean you're
good um what can i have what can you
have from my house ooh how about an iron
bob pop
oh an iron sign by iron bob
himself there you go add it to the
gifted suburbs
and the other guy who said iron bomb
he'll sign it as well uh you
jane zombob reboot i heard you had uh
five thousand [ __ ] viewers the other
day while you were playing about that
game what game were you playing there
well guy we should play it
i i've got not many people were
interested in it what is their nudity in
it why did that make people want to
watch you play the game
no it's a new game have sex with the
game is that why people are like you're
gonna play it but i'm hoping i don't
know if we can play it together we can't
probably
but i want you to play at least one
match and you'll see it's super fun
uh i don't even have time because i know
we're on a schedule but it's
it's his little guys that walk around
it's like peanuts buff shaggy69 says he
already got his ironbob pop today damn
it
wonder woman at wonder woman sass says
you guys are great why
thank you that means the world oh uh the
josh guy says what's movies website
again moviespopup.com yes somebody put
the link right there
uh we're at 27 on level four of the hype
train
uh we got ourselves the bear went over
the mountain a couple minutes ago when
it looked like we might not be making it
into level four but worked comfortably
at level four and we do have two minutes
of change
two minutes twenty seconds but there you
go oh my
hatchet thank you for subscribing well
done who who did it uh
molly hatchet made us molly had a little
bit molly more
uh anna anna took six six as a kid
ah they're going so fast now they go so
fast
there you go is this and then scroll the
wheel up the other way
said something about she uh she saw a
movie a dogma and was the first time she
ever saw
a movie where somebody had her name her
name must be bethany
yeah uh who was that heads thank you ned
heads for the gifted subs that got us 52
net heads you mean like you're talking
will
i mean maybe well
he should be handing you bits don't you
bit him up
he should bite you um tkbs says
i enjoyed my birthday kevin i did i
liked being above ground
was great aging is always better than
not aging
kevin who's your favorite film
soundtrack composer
what a great question in my world uh i
love jim venable
who's done a lot of scores for us chris
drake did an amazing
tusk score for us um uh
let me see um who but who do i like
outside i mean
obviously i've liked everyone who scored
on movies but who do i like
in the other world or the world of
people that
uh score you know of course i grew up on
john williams so
all the john williams scores are amazing
um danny elfman
was like i know you know batman made
elfman a household name but
i loved him from scrooge he did the
score for scrooge and he's really
memorable
oh sorry holly hatchet just gifted five
five tier one subs taking us to
78 with 34 seconds left to get to level
five ladies and gentlemen 21
21 we need a percentage a second in
order for us to make it starting
now oh my god and it's climbing it's
climbing man 33.
i feel my pulse rising you're gonna give
a heart attack victim another heart
attack if we don't get to level five
ladies and gentlemen
14 seconds in order for us to get 14
more percent
ladies and gentlemen we're running out
of time seven
six five oh no it's not oh it happened
you did it
thank you 65 subs though 31 50 butts
thank you guys it did end at level
three four four three four well we
almost we didn't finish level four
it's great though what the living
fun um buffy uh
shag says love your movies man come to
horror hound indy when it opens again we
were supposed to go to
what was i supposed to go to right
before they oh
it was in ohio we have san diego no in
ohio there's like it's not horror hound
but it's something like that it was like
a
horror show and there was always all the
mall rats kids were gonna go instead
yeah uh they canceled it like right
before when covet happened and stuff so
they moved it's i think next
cincinnati uh traymonk says i know we
were supposed to do horror hound i think
um but we were supposed to do a few
there was a few things i know i was
supposed to do some
uh you know a couple of the stand-up
shows that
at the comedy clubs which uh got
postponed which is a bummer
um
decorated box i got kevin's men
well what what yeah i need
uh sorry sorry someone said do you like
the i don't know why it didn't show up
the uh would it be on this side are they
donating yeah it should be in the mini
map let me um maybe it's because the
alert thing's off
something weird is going on because the
alerts are popping up but it was
not it was horhon cincinnati that got
cancelled thank you
um let's see what else we got going on
here
did you see that video of those two kids
watching or listening to
[ __ ] phil collins is amazing
it was like they just discovered phil
collins recently
and it chased that track up the chart it
was i i can feel it
coming in were they doing
things they weren't singing like they i
guess they have a youtube show where
they just sit there and
listen to music that they didn't grow i
mean they're younger they're like
[ __ ] like under 20 it looks like or
something so they sit there and listen
to songs that like we know very very
well
but it's so endearing so like they they
listen to
uh whitney houston singing and i i will
always love you yeah yeah
and you just watch like at first you
know they they give everything a shot
man they're just like
there for it but then things like hit
them the way they've hit people for
years yeah but you've just never seen
like nobody's ever had a camera on them
when they heard
like you know whitney houston sing that
song for the first time
and you watch people go like like
reacting to the singing is pretty
amazing man
they should give those dudes a show i
don't know why this is let me do one
other thing
am i just chatting about 216 said phil
collins easy loving
easy lover
[Music]
do you think all movies are gonna be
filmed in canada vancouver nowadays says
man named truth
uh look canada doing a hell of a job
uh battling kobit so you know i could
see a lot of people down here would want
to go up there to shoot a movie
i just imagine the canadian government
might be like ah
stay down aaron keep your kovad with you
um
that's that's one person in the canadian
government that's not all the canadian
government but in any event
i could see i'm sure it is now i'm sure
we're probably
[ __ ] prohibited from traveling to
canada at this point our coveted numbers
are so bad so i could see
all of los angeles and all of the film
business down here wanting to go up
there uh i just don't know if vancouver
is going to be
rushing to welcome us you know until we
make sure i mean they're going to
quarantine people for like two weeks
minimum when you get up there and stuff
so i'm all for it i just don't know if
canada is ready for
that much production or vancouver
particularly i mean cooper is already an
over-tax city when it comes to
production
so many shows shoot up there so to
suddenly be like now it's double because
other shows can't shoot in like you know
georgia or someplace else
be massive um you guys sound kinda loses
frog
that's why i was just going over to
switch this
tremock says i paid 850 bucks for
horhound to see eight usq people
and they canceled and won't refund are
you [ __ ] me
that ain't right man like it's one thing
to cancel but like
to be out 850 and not enjoy
what you paid for it that ain't right
man we gotta send trey mock something
uh trademark also traymonk
sorry he got the worst luck so first he
got his movies yeah
tighten this up uh so that it doesn't
work i know i was trying to
swap once trademark got his
movie first he got his movies that the
he was one of the guys with the fedex
got
messed up and it came two days later so
it was melted oh [ __ ] you got [ __ ] but
did they make good for him
yeah i believe so but even worse then
like three days later he got his iron
bob and he was damaged from the ups
guys are you [ __ ] me where wait says
traymock yeah where are you
where's traymonk live it's coming next
week he said
uh where do you live traymark yeah like
because i just don't want to live there
apparently they don't respect
ohio they're not respecting the mail out
there are they um
i'm glad that uh movies pop-up and and
um
gold belly were able to make that right
i know they went out of their way they
were heartbroken
uh the first like hundred orders or
whatever of the first like
250 they sent out there were 100 orders
that like ups
put in the wrong truck or something and
then the the food
uh didn't make it in time so a lot of
people sent pictures of like what the
[ __ ] am i supposed to eat this
so hopefully movies pop-up has been
making good for everybody kevin
would you ever do another short with
your cast of characters like flying car
says math 54
absolutely um after we've just like now
we've done nine weeks of
sun and lockdown on celebrity show-off
those are short films that's the most
amount of short films i've ever made
like in my life we call them like
sitcoms because they're shirt sitcoms
but
they're really like short films so i'd
be game man
like especially like he's right down the
street
yeah we could do a series of jay and
some although it'd be weird to see us
in california no i guess we did that in
both movies we eventually go to
california
i i have ideas i have ideas i'm trying
to throw him we'll see
listen this guy i have ideas i'm the
captain now
no happy late birthday kevin says man
manitou thank you
um boy they're going so fast kyle the
bearded gamer says
hey jay you're going to get kev to come
play d and d with us you play d d
i've been playing sundays yeah every
sunday now the [ __ ]
you want to see my yeah your avatar my
sweet transition no wait look at this
what to
playing a game playing dnd well that's
what that opening for but check this out
i'm going to
spoil it now but watch when i switch
from this to this you'll see it on that
screen ready
yes why can't you put on this screen
where i'm already looking
so i'm not giving the worst angle of
myself today
see i got to do this otherwise i'm like
no no it's right here though it's not
too bad
yeah i know i'm having to keep my face
straight to the camera and look over
here
so that's your dnd transition and then
the opening that you saw right like this
yeah where you're putting the sword yeah
[Music]
sword and the stoner oh that's badass so
anyway but that's that but our we're
gonna that's badass
is that do they use the game of thrones
music no no it's better not man
otherwise i'm sure like no it's
different
there aren't they like cracking down on
twitch where they're like you can't show
that you can't say no it's a bummer i
haven't been playing any music i used to
like sing people happy birthday with
that bert luke song
dalaway says kev shouldn't jay have a
sequel to logan yeah man when are you
going to impregnate that wife of yours
more babies more babies i j at one point
said he's like i don't even know if i
could have another kid he's like i love
my kids so much i can't imagine
having to feel that twice like it's just
he
he thought it would be very overwhelming
and not overwhelming to be like
there's too many kids around here but
just like how
how much he loves logan he's like how am
i supposed to divide that how am i
supposed to
you know and right now you can't even go
in the room with
everything going on i can't i mean i
know it'd be nine months from now but
um reboot question jay jay said he
didn't
visit justice because they wouldn't let
them [ __ ] justice was scared jay would
be mad because she had a baby
wouldn't let them [ __ ] is jay really the
dead yes they've
when they [ __ ] i have an answer for
this when they they [ __ ]
on in jane silent bob strike back the
night of the premiere
when will when you know uh will smith
when she was will smith
will ferrell when uh cap marshall will
and holly she was just like are these
cuffs really necessary it's like oh
don't make me shoot you justice and then
they go to the party across the street
uh you know after the dance you know
that's when jay
and justice were able to have sex is
what i thought when i wrote it
yeah came right from the writer's
imagination
can i get a congratulations from you
legends for getting hired on by
microsoft today says ringo 95
81. you did it you're working you got
that microsoft
bastards and you made them see sense man
you're going to change that company
they're going places now because of you
uh random bra bro broad
says kevin for marvel cam hashtag kevin
from marvel cameos oh
what a dream that would be but there was
only one marble cameo guy
we all know that sadly he can't be with
us anymore
sorry this is right side the bigs before
i asked about this
that gas is not me i just want folks to
know
that was not me i forgot this was from
uh go bigs one of our
my oh this is the box that they were
just asking about did you get the box
i got the box man how awesome kev
wishing you 50 more happy 50th birthday
mrs miller happy birthday from go bigs
88 micah um what it's
should we do it like uh hey you can open
it up no what's that move a seven what's
in the box
or like james alan bob what's in the box
here you go
you didn't think you were gonna see us
open a box today did you well
we don't aim to disappoint it happens a
lot but we don't aim to disappoint
opening the box this time i get to open
the box never mind you
done and look it's got pictures of me
all over it how dope man
all right but wait a second
that is gorgeous all right no i i no i
it will open but it's
it's really tight because mine did the
same thing is it meant to be open
like should i not open it
don't want to break it where i'm like
why won't it open and like no it's just
a
box no it opens it opens it just takes a
sec
[Music]
who
yeah is what m fly uh
i feel like no i don't think i'm
supposed to open it
yeah he says yes yeah yeah i feel like
maybe jay should open it that way if he
breaks it i could be like you idiot
mine was really tight too so let's see
if i could do it that's what she said
look at this you put your weed in there
says tim
at the lot on spot timmy it is right wow
honestly i hope movies takes off and
takes taco bell
place and demolition man says crazy eye
carl
i don't know if that's gonna happen
crazy our call but i like that there's
even one it kills me man it's so funny
two grumpy dudes gaming
says kevin was glad i got to see you in
fargo best damn show ever thank you for
going oh my god i love those fargo shows
jay literally left the room to go get
tools to open that box that's how
that's how tough it was he'll be back
i'm sure
um talking uh his
feel fear says kevin have you ever met
robert downey jr
i have um at the uh san diego comic con
uh they're coming off stage for
iron man 2 panel i'm in the back
uh loading dock area of the comic-con of
the san diego convention center
he did it oh and there's stuff inside
oh my lord man and look there's a
picture of us
on the stream at movies how awesome and
even the big inside of the box is
decorated
man this is dope many thanks
believe me and i will use this box i put
the box on my desk and i put
a laptop on top of it because i got two
laptops and stuff one for right and one
for
porn so this is going to go right on top
thank you
uh go biggs and mrs miller that's really
sweet
so in any event i'm backstage at san
diego comic con
i'm having a cigarette on the loading
docks freight elevator comes down
and favro who i've known for a few years
not like we're not like [ __ ] super
tight but i've known jon for a while
i've met him before is what i'm mean to
say um
i don't and have never met robert downey
jr
and gwyneth was with them and i knew her
like for a minute when she was dating
ben affleck like years ago
so i assumed like you know um
as they came out like favreau looked
over
and gave me one of those and i was
smoking a cigarette so i was like you
know
robert downey jr like looked and then
walked right over to me very briskly and
like
shook my hand he was like hey man i'm
robert excellent to meet you i've always
wanted to meet you and i was like
thanks uh so that was [ __ ] awesome
magical that's the only time i ever met
the guy
um you know he's he's pretty damn like
sober as sober as jay is
i would say if you can believe this or
not because jay of course just did his
sober birthday 10 years sober birthday
not too long ago as we all know
but as sober as he is like robert downey
jr is like really hardcore about it from
what i understand
so i don't think i'm a person as
somebody who smokes weed i don't
probably not a person that he would ever
care to be around i guess
or need to be around or something like
that i don't know i asked here
i asked one day i asked my agent like
years ago i was like oh man can i get
robert johnny jr on a podcast and uh he
was like
robert robert's pretty straight and
sober and clean dude he's going your
house reeks of weed i don't think that's
gonna happen i was like all right
now i think about my agent was always
like kind of like you can't do that i've
never really had an agent that's been
like you could do
anything you want my first stage and i
was like i want to make a jaws move and
they're like well that's something you
maybe do
10 20 years from now and i was like all
right what if downey jr called you then
i was like listen man morton downey jr
called me
robert the mouth himself i would have
been like what no robert downey's like
i'll come over but you got to stop
smoking weed for at least
two days so the house smells done in a
heartbeat
i wouldn't even see that i wouldn't even
be like well that's awfully presumptuous
i'd be like i get it
and he's like i want you to stop for a
month and i'll come into suit
and then that's a tough one because
[ __ ]
seeing him in the suit and taking all
those pictures my [ __ ] instagram
would blow
up but smoking weed is really good
and giving it up for a month i mean the
[ __ ] kind of cruel nonsense
why is he such a bastard robert downey
jr all of a sudden cardboard
cowboy says he shows up in the suit and
says look i want to be in your jaw's
boobie
shark
done and done i'm like hey [ __ ] shirt
wearing the suit he's like yes oh my god
we're gonna make so much money
that'd be weird every time people like
here comes the here comes the moose in
the movie
and it's [ __ ] robert downey during
the iron man suit and he's like
people like how did you get away with it
the new avengers game wait till you get
it i
debate it i only got to play you played
it that's not my speed i'm on a nintendo
switch playing [ __ ] mall brawl you
think i'm ready for that avengers game
it's so fun
uh they added a new suit right i saw
something that they added a new
character
or hawkeye or some sort yeah they've uh
well they only again it was the beta so
they only had a few characters but when
it comes out it's gonna
get bigger like they're gonna have more
characters but i we should i show you
before you have to go
uh fall guys i don't know if you want to
try one game of it or you want to just
keep chatting it's up to you
uh hitman the third says does jay not
smoke weed anymore is he sober from that
too
yeah my man's like sober as a judge as
they used to say back in the day
he don't smoke weed he don't drink you
smoke weed he don't drink
sounds like a list of complaints he
don't smoke weed he don't drink he don't
do nothing
but yeah he's he does this this is his
[ __ ] drug
mainline's the [ __ ] twitch
muse did you speak with kevin about the
fortnight thing says tkbs what is the
fortnight thing uh i don't know
oh no no well i sent an email that nut
guy says jay there's an old ass man in
your chair
[ __ ] you there's uh
there's i sent an email myself but
he gave me an email to epic because
everyone says
constantly that we should have a blunt
man in chronic or jam bobskin
because they have a deadpool fortnite
yeah they have uh
kids i'll be honest with you i agree
with you as i'm sure my uh
compatriot over here we would love to
see those skins we're just not quite
that popular
deadpool as you know very popular batman
very popular the star wars characters
aquaman very popular
jay and sal and bob have what you call a
cult following
um i don't know that we're strong enough
to warrant
a a fortnight skin
skins i would love it believe me i'm not
fighting it but i just
i'm a realist i've been in the kevin
smith business for like 26 years now and
i just don't i think we'd have to pay
them to do it
you know i think they'd be like well if
you give us like a million bucks
or if you stop smoking weed for a month
i'm like who are you robert downey jr
uh you should be that popular
uh thank you for that i wish we were but
i
look i don't i'm happy with the
popularity we have
um i've lived this long without being a
fortnight's skin
it would be nice though but we'll see i
think oh my god we want it so bad
relevancy it'd be nice though yeah
nobody's fighting it i mean [ __ ] i like
playing the 8-bit version of us
i've been playing he got me uh a
nintendo switch for my birthday and so
i've been playing mall brawl
constantly at night like late at night
it'll be two in the morning and i'm like
i still can't get past patrick swayze
it's yeah dude people keep on here keep
telling me how they got to the
golf thing and they're i saw like
because we they sent us the video clips
of all the screens because we shot that
episode
of sun and lockdown where me and austin
were playing it and i'm like there's a
[ __ ] monster
like there's a this there's a bunch of
[ __ ] that i'll probably never see
because i suck
i suck at gaming wayze is almost like
god now
really truly uh peaceful rivals is kevin
and jam a huge fan i've seen every movie
kevin's ever made my husband introduced
me to clerks in 2009 i was hooked
thanks for all the great movies thank
you you're welcome oh my god i'm glad
you like them
i don't know how great they are um but i
sure liked him and i think he's very
funny in him
um donald's shadow says i think there
are enough followers of j muse that the
skins would be a hit
look i'm with you but i ain't i don't
got the power
over at fortnight yeah everyone on here
right now 15
29 peeps all you guys send an email to
epic
and i'm sure epic would be like all
right 15 29 what do they charge for skin
uh it's like 1200 v bucks i'd say five
bucks and maybe
something like that so they're like it
ain't worth it for us 1500 they're like
we need something like a million people
want to buy the skin and then we'll do
your silly blunt mannequin
and i'm like all right mr [ __ ]
fortnite we'll be back
and you're gonna hear is there a mr
fortnite i'm
somewhere out there i bet you hear me mr
fortnite
holmes moriatti holmes moriarty you know
what that is right yeah that's
sherlock holmes and mariotti oh cause
you watched the
benedict cumberbatch how interesting
like my
reference to holmes moriarty is actually
from the books and classic reading and
stuff
and now you can join in that as well
because you watch the tv show
no reading involved exactly and the
lesson here kids
reading blows um let's see uh
cumberbatch
why what do you say did i say cumber
patch
just like i said ankle dope my mom used
to say clumberlin farms
and she's like go down to clumberland
farms and get an etherman's cake
ready and miss reading question mark
superman
j my click commander look some people
are fighting me going i'd buy a skin
hey i don't even play fortnite and i'd
buy a skin i just don't think we're
popular enough
i mean and believe me i would love to
sit here and be like we are the king
shits i just
can't look for tonight ain't called yet
and my man's been saying fortnite out
loud every day for the last like [ __ ]
two years so that's
that's what i'm basing it on but i'm
with you i say the whole game should be
[ __ ] jay and silent bob's fortnite
every character should be a view excuse
skin you should be able to play
coey london you should be able to
play rick darris uh all the the
not even the main chara not even like
the holden mcniels and the dantes and
the randalls man you should be able to
play
the eliases who the [ __ ] wouldn't want
to be elias
we're gonna check in there because
cardboard said an australian streamer by
the name of loose fruit
has about 1500 viewers per stream he has
a skin in fortnight
loose fruit beat us damn you lose fruit
uh fish flashy gremlin has a little mood
he said she okay sorry
lose food damn you girl lady loose fruit
uh what's up gentlemen this is cardboard
prison how are you
met you guys forever ago back in
keanesburg new jersey hope all is well
what the kingsburg that's the magic word
that's way back
we come from a place very near kingsburg
and one of us flat out lived in
kingsburg for a while
there used to be a commercial when i was
a kid come out to keanesburg amusement
park
they had a little amusement well very
little they had a board
there was cool for me i mean living
living down the street from a small
boardwalk was cool
why was it like were you like the lost
boys and [ __ ] you were a vampire yeah
preying on people who were there for a
good time you're like i'm gonna suck
your blood
brothers you were like i'm gonna suck
your pud and they're like don't you mean
blood and you're like
nope no i don't
uh kev i got a happy birthday from jay
can i get one from
from youtube my name's connor happy
birthday connor
happy birthday happy birthday
happy birthday birthday to you
uh i thought pizza was the magic word
says the mikey d show of course it is
tyson the internet champion what the
[ __ ] summit cardboard prison wrote let's
be real
let's be real keansburg was terrible
what
i said the boardwalk was cool being if
you lived in a town where you could walk
a block and go to a boardwalk that was
sort of cool
kevin and jay what is your
favorite location you've ever shot at uh
uh for obvious reasons quick stop very
very affectionate that started our
careers but
uh we've just been shooting sun and
lockdown for celebrity show off
at my house for the last nine weeks
that's my favorite location shoot
because i literally rolled out of bed in
a [ __ ] bathrobe and t-shirt
and we went to work most days i was like
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is the life uh kevin is the
blunt mobile an actual working vehicle
says blood
blooded rage one a no but there is a
chassis car chassis with a you know fake
body built on it for jay and silent bob
strike back
and then the one that you might have
seen in the background of
jane zombob reboot in the blunt cave uh
armin
kevorkian our visual effects guy also
the visual effects guy for
all the cw shows as well uh he built
that car and put it into the background
the car doesn't even exist man
um he built the entire blunt cave to for
as a matter of fact
uh that was just like one big wasn't
even the whole green screen studio was
like
there was some green two green walls
popped up and armin kind of did the rest
um let me see
art of matthew says would you guys ever
shoot in georgia
much love from atlanta yeah and harpy
man tough to get into georgia because
there's so much production there
i mean right now of course there's a lot
of covet everywhere in the united states
but pre-covet
georgia atlanta particularly was tough
to move into because all the crews were
already spoken for
uh because they all work consistently
aside from the walking dead tyler perry
has a studio there from what i
understand and stuff so
crew base is very uh spare there because
all of crew has been sucked up by the
many productions that work there all the
time
so i remember at one point uh for jane
salabab reboot we were looking at
atlanta but we just couldn't put a crew
together because they were all working
on other things
look i got an answer for everybody i do
you do they told me that when i was a
kid my mom's like you got an answer for
everything and i do
uh i don't know if you want to like
start saying
because i don't want you my old lady to
get mad i don't know if you want to
start saying goodbye so you don't have
to rush or what you feel like doing
yeah i got about 10 minutes i just have
to go into the other
into the other room because i think
jordan's on it as well
oh okay um so yeah we got a few more
minutes
what up socrates 47. look at the room
climbed up to 1600 yes
50 people we started with like 200 now
there are a bunch of people
bored as we are enough to watch this
[ __ ]
someone said is joey lauren adam's going
to be in mall rats too
uh said hey h8
durie hate derry uh yes i mean
if she wants to she's written into it uh
gwen her character
from mall rats is back so as long
hopefully joey's into it i mean she came
back for uh reboot but of course that
was like a great scene
um i can't imagine she won in it's gonna
be fun
we'll make it we'll make it easy very
easy owner um
group all our scenes together so we can
shoot her and get her out and stuff
i think so i think it's safe to say i'm
saying tentatively yes
i look for me i'm saying yes but you
gotta ask her
go to joey's twitch channel where right
now she's about to play
avengers that would be awesome
he's like finally i'd have something to
talk to joey adams about
the avengers game you should tell
everyone too don't forget uh that kevin
that kevin smith club
uh lame boy color says i made a
uh petition or something like that for i
made a petition for fortnite skins mods
allow link
yeah let's get that petition going man
nice one more place to be kept digitally
live because one day i assure you
try as i might then i i can't stay in
this world one day my body's like my
heart
already attacked me once once
um so one day i'm gonna drop dead it'd
be nice to know
that i left behind a skin in fortnite
so that people like he's gone but i'm
still playing him
here's a good one uh plus i'd be able to
dance
oh my god that'd be the best part do all
the emotes i wouldn't have to i'd just
be like
i'd hold up my phone and be like
renegade renegade
renegade now do you know all of them i
don't know how to do them i want to
learn them some of them are really
why we don't have to learn them if they
make us a skit that's true we don't
make us a skin because we don't want to
have to learn how to dance i'm 50. how
old are you
46 yeah we're too old to learn how to
dance oh you can't teach an old dog new
tricks but you can re-skin them
um there's the uh j music cabin we met
in 2014
nycc i was a photographer and we were
just chilling third floor of the javits
center and you gave me some great
inspirational advice just wanted to say
thank you again new jersey represents
said b in
b and why gaming um i'm not
i i remember being up on
uh the javits because i was probably out
there grabbing a smoke right
if i remember correctly well we were
waiting for i think we were waiting to
meet chuck too right at one point
yes to take pictures with the j and bob
yeah with the blunt man crying
oh and i got to see uh it was before
daredevil came out and i got to see
vince vaughn
i vince dinofrio uh with his head shaved
ready for a [ __ ]
he's always going on about he's like
duck guy that boy he always calls him a
boy that boy's a good actor
i'm like number one he's a man and he's
older than you number two of course he's
a good actor he was
[ __ ] in uh you know private pile
in uh full metal jacket [ __ ] where he's
like hey joker
he's been amazing forever but his
[ __ ] performance as wilson fisk is
sublime
remember when he [ __ ] like popped the
fucker's head off with the door he's
like oh
oh oh oh
nuts uh j muse you're on the twitch main
page
oh what the oh my god
we were just we were happy to talk to
200 we were elated to talk to 1600
we just jumped to 8 500 viewers quick
take your top off
that's the only way we keep people
nudity
that's lovely man welcome everybody hit
a follow all 8
000. yeah or sign the petition yeah sign
them get us skinned
we want to get skinned in the in the
fortnight there you go
uh all right let's see what else are we
doing what are you guys opinion
of a young jack nicholson playing
wolverine or logan
i mean that's a brilliant idea but
achievable very expensive i don't think
anyone's gonna back that play but i will
co-sign that
i was just thinking you know they said
the other day that shia labeouf
um is in the running perhaps
they said for ice man
uh because you know sooner or later of
course the x-men are going to come into
the marvel cinematic universe
and it looks like if they're talking
about ice man that might mean they're
going with the actual original lineup
from
you know the very first x-men comic book
which of course does not have wolverine
in it so maybe they're letting
themselves build up to wolverine
however when they said shia labeouf as
iceman for a second before they said
iceman i said
he could actually be [ __ ] wolverine
does anybody else
agree in the chat i'm just kind of
curious am i crazy for thinking that
or do you think shy i mean you get i
watch the tax collector he's [ __ ]
menacing man
he's a wonderful actor and you know
wolverine being what he is
like you know he's always been hugh
jackman in the movies and stuff but in
the comics he's
little like back in the day they want
you know people were like danny devito
should play him and stuff like that
so i'm not saying shy as little he's but
he doesn't have to be like super
although he can put on bulk and [ __ ]
i just think he's a really good actor
yeah yeah i could see him doing that
there's a lot of
yeah yeah yeah yeah right you know i
don't think i was crazy because when
they said shia labeouf sniffing around
or they're sniffing around shia labeouf
for a mcu movie i was like
[ __ ] wolverine because that'd be
genius and then when they say ice man
i'm like whatever that kid does i'll
watch he's a really good actor
he he is the movie he did call honey
honey boy
i didn't see that one so [ __ ] good he
plays his father
was he young indiana jones too wasn't he
yeah but don't bring that up but it's
not that
young indiana jones he played mutt uh in
yes in
indiana jones and the and the crystal
skulls and stuff
um we're at 8 500 people right now 10
000 people so we're
we have a meeting we're about to go to
i'm gonna jump out for five minutes
jumping out for five minutes and coming
back meanwhile jay
is gonna do his level-headed best to
keep you all here i suggest
nudity full nudity but before i step out
of this
what's the next big kevin smith movie we
should be looking for him all rats two
clerks three
did you get randall back says hitman the
third um
twilight of the mall rats is written and
then i just
started writing the new version of
clerk's three
so it's you know it's it's all coveted
dependent honestly
um it's really not even up to us even if
i have the scripts and the money ready
to go
nobody's doing anything right at this
moment in time the industry's still
trying to figure out how to like let
people go back to work and stuff
but as soon as there's something to talk
about believe me i'll let you know i'm
going to come right back we're going to
do a quick phone meeting jay's going to
sit here
keep him entertained i'm going to try
yes yeah give away some cbd man
cbd wow says
all right guys i mean this with 10
412 people please everyone hit a follow
um and welcome this is awesome
the bummer is like he said he has a
meeting but he will be back
it's just literally like he him and uh
the wife have to do a zoom call
um and kevin will be back everybody
kevin will be back
uh and we'll answer tons of questions
i'm trying to get him to play fall guys
anyone knows thank you falsely donald
shadow what is up i know guys this is
awesome i think this might be our record
this might be the record i don't know
but welcome everyone
pop mask thank you for subscribing um
guys um yeah so we are definitely going
to
i'm going to try to talk him into doing
playing some fall guys
i don't the only bummer about that is um
i don't know if we can play
side by side like i don't think we get